our first question is people jeremy
congratulations
uh your speech was just incredible uh
it was maybe the most moving moment of
the night uh you mentioned your mother a
lot in that speech and what she taught
you
did you get the sense as as you were
talking up there that maybe you know
she's
shining down smiling down on you as you
were able to deliver that message that
she first gave you
and you know i could feel her in the
moment i could feel her any time i'm up
there i'm carrying her
with me and all that she went through
and all we went through together so
you're absolutely right about that
jeremy
next question beauty rhyma next question
wwd rhymer congratulations
hi it's rima but i get that all the time
and it's totally cool
congratulations i was just repeating
what she said remember
no worries at all i i wanted to ask you
what inspired you
to share such a personal story
just where we are in the country in the
world everybody's grabbed a corner and a
color and they're all
nobody wants to come to the middle to
have a conversation everybody's
polarized and and it's in the middle
where things change so i'm hoping that
that inspires people to meet us
in the middle so that we can get back to
some semblance of normal
as this pandemic is over we can all get
to a place
where we're showing love and kindness to
each other again
our next question is extra rachel extra
rachel
hi tyler congratulations such a huge
honor tonight
i have to ask you your speech was so
powerful and you talked about meeting in
the middle why was it so important for
you to put that message in your speech
tonight
i just think because there's so many
people that are forgetting is in the
middle is where
conversation happens and that's where
change happens when you're talking
and experiencing each other what what
everybody's going through and being able
to put yourself
in being able to put yourself in someone
else's shoes and have empathy for those
situations i think
that only happens in the middle so
that's my hope that more people would
just meet in the middle